i forgot to ask you this but at what
point
in your career did you end up going to
north korea oh the north korea so north
korea was one of the craziest things i
did
was this after rockstar this is way
after watson okay
this is actually recent north no no not
north korea is
maybe five years ago okay five or six
five years ago so
um north korea was after
after uh steve harvey because i remember
i was like i got to do something big
this year
and then and i was looking in the ittf
which is international table tennis
federation
website they have all the pro tour
tournaments
and then i saw north korea i was like oh
my god
i gotta go to north korea and dennis
rodman i just came back from north korea
oh [ __ ] and i was like yo i gotta go
freaking north korea i gotta go north
korea
so i call my friends all around the
world i say hey
you guys wanna play a tournament in
north korea we can go do
a diplomacy for world peace so
historical moment in america 1971
yeah america established relations with
china through ping pong called the ping
pong diplomacy hence you got the movie
forrest gump
so i wanted to do my own ping pong
diplomacy i wanted to do my own
to north korea because at the time nor
north korea
was uh uh uh um really
really against america and and and
and i figured dennis rodman went there
he didn't really do much there
i definitely can go and do something
right so um i saw the tournament and
i i call people say hey um let's go
everybody's like no you're
crazy i'm not going to north korea
you're going to die there people like
you're going to die
you're not going to come back they're
going to it was all kinds of crazy stuff
so nobody wanted to go then i tried
people from the us team let's go nobody
wanted to go so i was like all right
i'll go with myself so i called the u.s
team and said hey
um can you guys enter me into the north
korean pro tour
in pyongyang right and they were like ah
i said
no i want to go just enter me
because we can't enter ourselves into
pro tournaments
right so the u.s team has to enter you
right so
they entered me and then i got contact
from the
uh uh the consulate general of north
korea and
they were like oh so happy you're gonna
come to north korea blah blah
you know and um i was like oh this is
cause it's really happening
and then i saw my name on the list it
said wally green usa
pyongyang open and uh i
i wanted to go there to make a
difference that was the plan i wanted to
do
a diplomacy i had no idea or no clue
of how this was going to happen i didn't
know what i was going to do there was no
plan
i said but i want to do it so the first
step is to get there
so i wind up going there and um there
was a
one particular situation who set up the
whole trip for you
oh i did oh you set up yourself oh yeah
i was back and forth with the um
consulate i had to go to beijing can you
what's can you actually like buy a
flight to north korea from the united
states
no so so what you got to do is you have
to go to china
and then you go to china you go to the
consulate in china you get the visa in
china and then you're going to buy the
ticket in china
holy [ __ ] now here's now here's the
craziest thing about that
so when you buy the ticket in china
you saw i'll tell you to sir how it went
so i went to go buy my ticket
and um i go to um this is what i
couldn't even find
i couldn't even find the airline you
couldn't find anywhere so i wanted to
take a north korean airline because i
wanted the full effect
of what it is to go to north korea right
so they have one airline
so eventually in the airport people
trying to tell me go this way so i find
it if i
find it so i say yeah i want to go to
pyongyang
is my visa and they said it was like it
was like six seven hundred dollars
and um i give them my card and they say
oh
sorry sorry no no card so what you mean
no card
cash only yeah so i had to pay
cash for my ticket so so i i buy it i
had to go back out
to atm and you know to take 800 us
dollars
out in chinese money it's crazy it's
like you get all this cash running
around what is the conversion
i think it's uh what is it what do they
use yen no no no
they use r b what r and b r and
r r m b what the hell does that mean
r and b that's chinese currency
currency yeah and and if i remember
correctly
i can't remember what is it i can't
remember what is it
what the conversion rate but it's
definitely a lot too little
okay right so so uh i have to take all
this money out
and then pay them with it so they give
you a receipt but they didn't give me a
boarding pass
there's no boarding pass just a receipt
even receipt and they said okay god i
said but where's the boarding pass
they don't need it somebody's going to
pick you and they're going to bring you
to your seat
so i got escorted from there to my seat
so there was never no like sitting down
time it was from there
person took me took me to the plane
put me into my seat yeah it's very
the the process the whole process of
going there was was was really
it was really crazy what was it like on
the plane
so so when i got on the plane um i
noticed
every person had these pins these little
pins
every person had one and i was like
what's those pins i'm looking at the
pins
and the pins were either the current
great leader
that they call the great leader kim kim
kim jong-un
or his dad and the grandfather
or all three of them so everyone had a
pin on and and i
and i was looking as well i want to get
a pin i was like this is cool
so i asked the stewardess to say hey um
can i get a pin yo she gave me the
dirtiest look
i've ever gotten in my life it was cr
i mean she was acting like i was asking
her for sex
i just said can i get a pin she gave me
she looked at me
with this dirty look and i was like okay
i guess
that's a no and yeah so i mean everyone
had these these pins on and and uh
i mean the flight was normal it was fine
it was the seats were nice
like i have video of all this [ __ ] and
and the seats were nice it was a pretty
cool
flight and then you get the and you
arrive when you go downstairs
uh somebody comes to get you they come
pick you up they have a person that's
responsible it's called your guide
and they introduce themselves hey great
to have you blah blah
then they take your computer and take
your phone because they got to go
through that [ __ ] where they think oh
they go through
oh yeah they go because there's certain
things you can't bring in
and they had somebody a guide for you
why because you were an american
well that person's any any visitors like
westerners
okay are gonna have someone that's
responsible for them really
that person you're not gonna so you
can't leave your hotel and like
go have lunch right you can't you have
to be escorted you have to be esco you
actually you can't even go anywhere so
for me every day my everyday was the
same it was
get up go into the hotel lunch uh
dining room eat then she'd come pick me
up bring me to the practice hall then
she'd bring me to
the tournament hall then bring me back
to the practice hall
and back to the hotel so it's back and
forth so so there's nothing you can
really do
without that guide and that guide is
responsible
for uh you so they report back
so so they ask you a lot of different
kind of questions
which you have to be really careful like
people people don't realize
um no no north korea for for me
is the most dangerous country in the
world for
any westerner by far i don't care
you can go to taliban world it don't
matter north korea is more dangerous
because at least in taliban where i got
my passport i can get the hell out i
don't need to be there
right in in in north korea
you um don't have no cell phone service
you have no wi-fi you're not allowed
wasn't it not allowed wi-fi
or cell phone service so with that in
itself can't use the internet
no zero with that in itself you're cut
off from the world
that's it you're cut off the third thing
what makes it the most dangerous is that
when they check into the hotel they take
your passport
so now you have no passport no passport
no cell phone no wi-fi yeah you're
you're
you're in jail holy [ __ ] bro
yes were you freaked out a little bit i
was never i was never scared until the
end
because i guess i grew up in a project
with guns what was your your guide like
was it was you said it was a lady it was
so was she nice
so so here's the thing so before you go
there was she hot
yeah so so this is a trick listen before
you go there
they know everything about you
everything is planned nothing is by
chance so they
they know that i like asian chicks she
[ __ ]
listen man you'll be sitting in jail for
15 years talking about damn i know i
shouldn't touch that girl
they got no prostitutes over there you
you won't even you don't see
anything you you'll never get a chance
like
like listen listen they know that i like
asian chicks
so so they gave me this this girl this
this hot
hot asian girl and why me out of
everyone
has a hot asian model as a guy come on
that's
nonsense so the reason why they do that
is they want to make you feel as
comfortable
as you can feel so they can get
information from you
you